In language learning, you wanna
do it wrong the first time and you
want to continue doing it wrong.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here again
to talk about language learning.
And in particular, today I'm going to talk
about the need to get it right or, uh,
as, um, one often hears in, feels like
engineering or construction or industrial
production, get it right the first time.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So I worked for a forest products
company and we were making
lumber and pulp and newsprint.
And of course, quality control is
very important and as often happens
in large corporations, we get these
consultants to come in and run programs.
You know, six sigma and all these
other different, you know, buzzwords
around the idea of, of improving
quality, like fewer errors.
And there was one program they had in
one of our mills because the company
was quite sort of decentralized.
And this one pulp and paper mill
brought in a consultant who had
a program called DIRTY FOOT.
Do it right the first time.
And all the sort of management people
and, and production people had name
cards with DIRTY FOOT on the back and
they had a whole bunch of different
programs around the idea of making
sure that at every step along the
process, everything was done just right.
You know, met certain specific standards.
And the idea was do it right the first
time and then you don't have to redo it.
Now, how does that apply
to language learning?
Well, the short answer is it doesn't,
doesn't apply in language learning.
You wanna do it wrong the first time and
you want to continue doing it wrong, and
you wanna accept the fact that you're
going to continue doing it wrong if you
are too obsessed with getting it right
the first time or the second time, you
put unnecessary pressure on yourself and
you'll probably hold back and stay with
material that is easy enough so that you
can get it right, which is not a good idea
because you want to expose yourself to
as, as much of the language as possible in
as many different situations as possible.
And that's going to mean getting it wrong.
It's going to mean not understanding,
it's gonna mean answering questions
wrong with the wrong tense, or the
wrong, uh, preposition, or the wrong
ending, or any of these things.
You're gonna continue getting it wrong,
and you have to be willing to get it
wrong over and over again in order that
you get enough exposure to the language
that eventually you start to get it
right and, and very often I, I think
part of the problem here is the way we
were taught languages at school where
you don't, obviously you don't wanna
get it wrong on the test, you want to
get it right on the test, but what if
you aren't going to get it right until
you've actually had enough exposure
or until you've done it wrong enough
times that you start to get it right.
So Okay, get it wrong, but don't
penalize people for getting it wrong.
Maybe we congratulate
people for getting it wrong.
And encourage them, encourage them
to keep on getting it wrong, uh,
because eventually they're gonna
get it right with enough exposure.
So, uh, the idea that you're gonna
master the basics at some early stage,
like if you're building a house,
well, you've gotta get it right.
Uh, if you don't line things up square
or level, and then the floor isn't
level and you know, the, the stud
goes up and it is isn't at 90 degrees.
Now the wall isn't square and so many bad
things happen in many industrial processes
if you don't do it right the first time.
But that's not the case
in language learning.
It's not as if you're you, you're not
building something where if you get
it wrong at an early stage, then you
will build it wrong on top of that.
In fact, you will get some things right
and some things wrong, and this will
continue for quite a while, and at some
point the things you were getting wrong,
you'll start to get them right, but you
can't force yourself to get them right.
At least that's been my experience.
I encourage people to accept to own
their mistakes, and that's another reason
why, by the way, why I, why I'm not
a big fan of correcting other people.
If they ask for it, fine.
If they don't, just let them communicate.
Let them engage, say things, they
get input back, and gradually they'll
start to hear a more correct version
of what they were trying to say.
Yes, it's possible that some
people will have certain
errors that they never correct.
And, and I've seen this, people who
speak English very well, they'll have
certain patterns from their, uh, native
language that they never ever correct.
And they continue to use that same pattern
in English, for example, or in some
other language that they're learning.
However, my experience has been, even
if you correct them, they won't change.
So at some point they have to
naturally feel, develop a new
habit where this pattern they were.
, they switch to another pattern.
But in the meantime, in most cases,
if someone says to me, if a German
speaking person says, I have lived in
Canada since many years, which is not
correct in English, it's correct in
German, I understand what he's saying
or she, so it's not a big problem.
But if that person has lived in Canada
for a long time and is comfortable
speaking English, and I then say to
them, well, actually, while we're talking
about something that's of interest to
both of us, and then I jump in there
and say, oh, by the way, you keep on
saying that, but that's not correct.
If they ask me to correct
their language, fine.
But otherwise I would never do that.
I would just say live with that
mistake, either it'll naturally, you
know, self-correct at some point, or
that person will continue comfortably
communicating in English, even with
the odd trace of say, a German or a
Swedish or a French or a Japanese or a
Chinese, you know, turn of phrase there,
where based on my experience, even if
I correct them, it won't do much good.
So message is do it right the first
time is very important in industrial
processes, in manufacturing, in
construction and engineering.
But when it comes to language
learning, do it wrong.
Do it wrong, not only the first time.
Do it wrong many times
and accept your mistakes.
There you have it.
I look forward to your comments
and I've left a couple of videos
where I talk about the importance
of mistakes in language learning.
Bye for now.